hey youtubers is Charlie Game of Thrones
just released a brand new preview for
season four with a ton of new footage
and a lot of comments from the actors so
just like last time I wanted to do a
breakdown of all the new things we saw
quick heads up though because Game of
Thrones isn't coming back till April I'm
gonna be starting a special countdown
video series in March I'll have more
information about that in the Q&A video
that I'm gonna do on Wednesday be sure
to subscribe to get that but get excited
it's gonna be a lot of fun I'll be doing
a giveaway just like I'm doing in my
Walking Dead videos right now for this
video I'm only gonna be talking about
the new footage we saw because there
were a lot of scenes that were repeated
from that season 4 trailer in case
you're finding me for the first time
I'll have a link to that other breakdown
at the end of this video all the things
I talked about will just be in
chronological order of the appearance
they appeared in the HBO video careful
for spoilers if you don't want to know
anything but Hugh the Dragons let's go
in the pre-roll the forge is being used
to melt down Ned Stark's giant
two-handed Valyrian steel grates toward
it's being made into two smaller blades
the larger one on the left is Oathkeeper
and the smaller one on the right is
widow's wail - this is the new home
where Danny's dragons live beneath her
new home there's actually a screenshot
of that building later in this video
that I'll include remember that last
shot of drogon in the video yeah he's
big three Joffrey plays with one of said
new blades for Aria takes back something
she lost at the crossroads five bran
teaches jaime to learn to fight with his
left hand
six bran tries to communicate with the
three-eyed crow seven this is the first
good shot of the new actor playing
Daario 8 this is the red Viper and his
lover ilaria sand we didn't see her in
the season 4 trailer 9 the Hound at the
crossroads in the same scene that Aria
was in previously so this is where we
get to the actor interviews I'm actually
gonna skip a lot of the things they say
unless they have really important clues
about you know what's coming or offer
some details about things they change
from the books but continuing on 10
Wendel and Christy actually highlights a
really important thing that some of the
actors read ahead in the books and some
do not
she obviously did but a good example of
someone who does not pay attention to
the books is Peter Dinklage the ones
that don't mostly just do it out of
concern that it'll hurt their
performance for some really important
scenes like the wedding to Sansa
or all the big action set pieces of this
season 11 David Benioff actually says
something really important here that
some of the biggest scenes come at the
end of the season
we can talk more about the timeline in
one of my future videos maybe twelve
remember at the end of season three
Sansa did not know about the red wedding
thirteen if you look at the slate it
says episode six and in the background
you can see the red Viper Tywin and mace
Tyrell he's kind of fuzzy though there's
the people presiding over Tyrians trial
this is actually pretty huge so we can
all adjust our timelines accordingly 14
even though Cersei and Tyrion really
hate each other
Lena Headey and Peter Dinklage used to
share flat in Dubrovnik whenever they
were filming they're actually really
good friends in real life
15 Tyrion and Jaime spend a lot of time
together it's like the season of
brotherly love no not that twincest kind
of love 16
this is the first on set interview with
Pedro Pascal that HBO has posted he
hasn't officially said a lot about
himself as the red Viper before this 17
more slates
so this says from episode 5 in the next
slide you can actually see Cersei and
black so we can probably adjust our
timelines just a little bit more I hope
you're getting excited because it seems
like big events are getting pushed
forward and forward and forward in the
season 18 Rory McCann actually starts
all the Joffrey Roast clips at the
actor's film for that promotional stunt
HBO did earlier this year it was Maisie
Williams and a few of the other actors
making fun of Joffrey 19 this is a much
better shot of the royal wedding feast
20 the scene that they talk about that
takes up half the episode is most likely
the banquet and the wedding combined
look at all those extras it's the
biggest scene that they've filmed since
the season 1 premiere 21 the actors
talked about how amazing the sets are
the art designer Deborah Riley got a new
feature at that HBO dead earlier this
year and the art designer Gemma Jackson
from season 3 won an Art Directors Guild
Award for their work during that season
they have some of the best sets of any
show on television right now 22 the
evolution of the Dragons this is one of
the things that I'm most excited about
in season 4 David Benioff talks about
the challenges that come with
controlling the Dragons once they become
a really big 23 this is a good shot of
the library the Nights Watch or as close
to things they have to it there are
actually text in there that predate the
creation of the wall I always thought
that everything they needed to win
against the White Walkers were in those
books but because Sam is the only one
who reads them the chances of them
finding that critical information is
really slim 24 I just love the
Gwendoline Christie
almost giggling her way through
explaining this really violent thing
Brienne has to do to defend herself what
a lovable goofball 25 DB Weiss actually
says something really good here while
the red wedding represented this epic
set piece for season 3 season 4 has
several scenes that are on that scale 26
this is a really good external shot of
marine 27 Jamie unveils Brienne's new
arbor she's actually wearing it during
this interview and finally 28 let's
leave it on
drogon look at how much bigger he's
gotten he's the biggest of the three and
it becomes a huge issue in season 4 for
Danny he looks hungry better watch out
so this was a lot of fun again but there
is one more thing that I want to add
Maisie Williams said the good guys are
coming back but that was a bit
misleading the subtext is is that
everyone gets thumped on this season you
know the good guys in the bad and
technically no one's either you know
really good or really bad it's all
shades of gray unless you are Ramsay
snow that guy is just plain evil like I
said I'll be doing that Game of Thrones
Q&A on Wednesday so just write any
questions you want me to include that in
the comments right now click here for
that other season 4 breakdown video
careful for spoilers and click here for
my review of Walking Dead Season 4
episode 9 it just came back and it is so
awesome thank you so much you guys I'll
see you tonight
high fives
you